the standard version of electricity that
electricians learn
is that current is the flow of electron
beads from atom to atom
and from negative to positive poles
it is the outer valence electrons that
participate in this stream of particles
what induces this flow is said to be a
difference in potential
known as voltage widely simulated as
water running down a hill
think of a tank of water perched up high
connected to a pipe
that ends down below in a container it
is self-evident
that water will flow from the tank to
the container
but this is quite misleading the
simulation works not because of
electricity
but because of gravity
what do the terms positive and negative
mean in physical terms
what physical entity compels the
electrons to rush downwards toward the
positive pole
a more fundamental shortcoming of the
particle flow mechanism
is that it embossed a planetary model of
the atom
the negative electron is assumed to be a
tiny bead that is located somewhere
around the nucleus of the atom
what physical object prevents the speed
from flying away
what physical entity prevents it from
falling all the way to the nucleus
and what is it that induces the speed to
flow from atom to atom
to the positive voltage end
it is these types of questions that
remain unanswered even to this day
the rogue hypothesis proposes that the
electron is a membrane that encapsulates
the proton star
the atom is weaved by countless electric
and magnetic threads
converging upon it from every atom in
the universe
when an atom slides along the
electromagnetic rope towards another
it reels in the two threads that form
the interconnecting electromagnetic rope
through which light propagates
when the two atoms meet they either
blend
or push each other away depending on
whether their electron shells are
spinning in the same
or in opposite directions
for example if the cells are both
spinning clockwise
the atoms screw into each other and form
the h2 gas
molecule if instead they spin in
opposite directions
the atoms push each other away and the
rope between them regenerates itself
imagine now a wire made entirely of iron
atoms
iron atom has an outer orbital structure
that looks more or less as seen here
under the rope model the s and p
orbitals are physical balloons that
encapsulate the nucleus
imagine now a long chain of blended iron
atoms that make up the wire
we refer to these chains as serpentines
when stimulated the entire serpentine
spins in place
a closed circuit resembles a doughnut
turning on itself along its entire
extension electricity is not the
shooting of bullets
electricity is more appropriately
visualized as a drill bit twirling in
place
in a vacuum chamber the serpentine
extends from cathode to anode
to illustrate voltage let's briefly look
at the basic lead battery
there are two terminals lead designated
as the negative pole
and lead dioxide the positive pole
these terminals are immersed in a
solution of sulfuric acid and water
a chemical reaction takes place that
induces electron beads to flow
to the positive pole under the rope
model of electricity
the reaction induces the entire
serpentine making up the wire
to spin clockwise from the point of view
of one terminal
the other end has no choice but to
rotate counterclockwise
voltage is clockwise and
counterclockwise spin of a serpentine
a series of atoms which are merged and
aligned
[Music]
you